secondo rari ragazzi su world golf senza
bisogno poi eravamo rimasti che perché
c'è la webcam horror ho sbagliato
teniamoci quella oro però rimasti che
abbiamo sporcato da parte del bowling
che va bè ciao proprio sono veramente
mega convinto che la parte del bowling
sia incredibile
non voglio sbloccarmi le corone di tutti
i livelli ma voglio provare fino a
finirli tutti perché la parte del
bowling l'ultima volta era stata geniale
praticamente tu devi lanciare la palla
in base a come gira e quindi mi viene
molto meglio lanciarlo al contrario
perché c'è più produzione praticamente
non sono spiegabili sta roba da romani
ma sì mi mancavano due livelli quindi
bolling hanno già fatto sta roba
scherzavo come dovrebbe funzionare
spiega p
ma è che fa il giro non lo fa il giro
dei pirla mi sono fatto la scena ci sono
pure cascata con il fatto lo avvertiamo
avanti ragazzi
bello questo seppur mai davvero fa mi
devo girare il primo facevo per caso ma
qua
porca vacca marco demonio si sfondava il
muro sarebbe stato bello e farlo
scavalcandolo salve mi avrebbe dato
molta più soddisfazione prova aperta
allora ok
manca solo 11 ragazzi sto già comunque
sta diventano incredibile cosa devo fare
qui mamma 12 sono stato bravissimo
perfetto
[Musica]
più vado avanti più non capì no ragazzi
non ha veramente un servigio rosso gioco
incredibile c'è più come fanno ad
inventarsi cagate ad ogni livello io non
lo capisco
no no suscito a morire è sempre bowling
sempre avanti
questo è uno solo che mi fece che ci
sono i minigiochi nella scelta del
livello strumentale
adesso ci sono le palle da bowling mensa
birillo ok alla fine me ne basta una va
bene riuscito a farlo o no questo
salvato a posto ce l'ho fatta con una
non ho capito niente di quello che è
successo probabile devo arrivare alla
fine
ok sembra una cagata è però usare le
palle per schivare le robe non è non è
facilissimo 12
ok belga ha già fatto ma la mia
costruisca c'è un duro un poco è
talmente bello che ci gioca resisto
giorno negli avanti ragazzi dunque sono
sia nel golf che nel bowling che nel
calcio vedo che me la cavo l'ultimo
livello del bowling teoricamente questo
che bowling nello spazio ma sto male
prova lanciate lascio al contrario lo
sapevo bene che ci siamo ne manca
ok non me l'aspettavo sta roba mi sembra
di trovare le stesse
lo stesso divertimento che avevo quando
giocava super mario galaxy non so se ve
lo ricordate ragazzi che mi salta vi nei
mondi un casino veramente figo
ebbene ci affidiamo fatto manca niente
ho finito ad opere delle corone anche
qua perfetto teoricamente con le corone
ti sblocchi una roba che non ho ancora
capito che cosa dovrebbe essere prova
vede vi chiamo più avanti dai la parte
col bowling l'abbiamo fatta manca la
parte sinistra della corsa a ostacoli va
bene stavolta ce ne sono solo due
livelli da completare va bene parte
sinistra avavano
cosa è e cosa vi rappresenta è chivu
copi ho acceso la fiaccola sport no
vabbè bellissima prova
andiamo avanti a manetta la manetta vai
salta tutto questo ragazzi non vuole
ricordarlo ma è un gioco di golf non
c'entra niente adesso questa azienda
un'altra roba
good sport mio dio sono le olimpiadi
praticamente vai vai vai vai uno
skateboard e devo fare il salto
incredibile sono bravissimo quindi
madonna che sai sta diventando veramente
trash come roba eccovi ho vinto e doveva
arrivare dalla parte sinistra troppo
avanti
jacques a bra cos'è sta roba dai sono
accaduto sono morto solo il tuffo finale
valeva il video ragazzi va bene ce l'ho
fatta mi batto il boss e vamonos prova
batterlo tutto senza mai morire molto
difficile ragazzi è un piacere o quasi
riuscito ciao pallina sei una rana in
che senso e salto gli ostacoli ops una
margherita non sono una ram anche senza
quindi che va va lento in questo senso
qui e penso di poter saltare le cose che
ho preso alla lettera mi aiuta fuorviato
porca vacca lo schivare gli ostacoli dai
l'ho preso no eh vabbè questo punto è
difficile dai già fatta
non era così difficile ciao faccio il
caffè ogni mattina non è vero mi sembra
un po un gioco fatto da ceo alle volte
comunque questo alla faccia un cesso
rotto hai trovato il nostro posto
segreto nuovo c'è un livello segreto di
un lavoratore segreto è proprio
difficile devi dargli la giusta o
sbagliata livello segretissimo ma
neanche per sbaglio sarei arrivato qui
maraval com ero solo questo gol frenata
37 in interior a segnalare il golf ha
ancora noioso e vero va bene davanti e
non passa di qua porca vacanza
incastrato non voglio guarda non ho idea
di che cosa possano essere le
i prossimi livelli ragazzi c'è questo
qua che mi attira particolarmente che
tutto bianco non ho capito che cos'è ma
qualche mib a perfetto guarda iniziava
da dio
cos'è tipo super hot a noi e super hot
ma come hanno fatto super 8 ma non ci
credo
no abbiamo elevato bacini
[Musica]
io non so io non so che cosa dire ve lo
giuro su per watt a posso anche sparare
c'è ma vi rendete conto
posso anche sparare ai due le persone
beh ormai non ho idea di come sia
possibile st genialata bellissimo no
ragazzi a mani basse il miglior gioco
della storia ci hanno fatto super hot
dentro non so se è chiaro bellissimo
quindi
vado giù 18 madonna che voglia di
giocare a super hot che ciò è c'era la
copertura però perfetto adesso mandato
l'arma prendila intanto sono mazze da
golf sono bravi sono bravo perché ho
giocato a super hot quindi sto bene le
tattiche sennò non sarei così in grado
di fare queste cose
l'altro anche e super8 anche il la parte
di livello che c'è prima di arrivare a
livello boh geniale ragazzi basta stai
fermo quando arrivare alle armi devo
risparmiare le secondo me le armi a
youtube bellissimo eccesso riusciti a
fare super8 perdenti in non in 2d perché
non è 2t occhio è qua devo schivare i
proiettili e che non arrivano mai
insomma fucka vacca molto particolari
luoghi prendi quello porca vacca lì sul
ma dopo melo schivato aiuto ce l'ho
fatta per un niente non ce l'ho ancora
fatto in attacco veloce velocissimo
perfetto sono stato un moto di fingersi
superpartes parte sarebbe non so cosa
voglia dire pattern in italiano per una
roba è un termine golfistico vivamente
bellissima star genialata veramente la
cosa più geniale del mondo
diamo avanti l'ultimo super hot tensione
ecco infatti però come faccio a prendere
le armi li devo colpire come faccio a
non li posso colpire devo solo schivare
ok cavalca veramente felici perché vanno
in linea dritta o semplicemente scolare
ok ok è tutto ok
ce l'ho fatta teoricamente c'è la dovrei
aver fatta perfetta super 8 ragazzi
vorrei aver finito
non vedo l'ora di fare le corone di
questi livelli ma magari non adesso
stanno veramente difficile paolo super
hot e lo abbiamo fatto manca la parte
sinistra
vediamo basilica ragazzi porta davvero
no ragazzi bellissimo ma geniale geniale
come gli è venuto in mente ma come gli è
venuto in mente di fare sta provata
incredibile
no ragazzi pazzesco giuro ci hanno fatto
portal sono innamorato di sto gioco
veramente vi do il riso ricompro sto
veramente pazzesco aiuto a posto
proteico dovreste aver giocato a porta
per capire ste robe io lo capisco perché
io l'ho fatto con i drive dove pure
studiarmi le cose per andare avanti ci
pensate
non devo solo fare il livello anche
studiarvi come fin come arrivarci
teoricamente dovrei averlo fatto
perfetto non era così difficile sono io
che sono un po stupido dare ai ragazzi
questa è la grande bisogno di volte golf
o io veramente non so come descrive il
suo meglio sempre sempre sempre meglio
bellissimo spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi consigliava nel prossimo
episodio finché non finisce quando
finirà lo rifarò tutto non va bene
scherzo però spero non finisca mai cosa
i ragazzi se vi sia piaciuto lasciate un
commento è un mi piace iscrivetevi
canale schiaccia della campania lina
vicina tasse scrivi e non è come sempre
ci hanno un prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]